[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 112 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing
today, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm good.
We've got a good podcast
for us this week.
We're going to be
talking to Mike, who's
Co-Founder and CEO of Percy.io.
And they are doing visual diffs.
But as always, before
we get into that,
we're going to do cool
things of the week.
And we're going
to have a question
at the end of the week--
or at the end of the week--
at the end of the actual talk.
Wait until the end of the week.
We're going to talk
about if you wanted
to know what the
news is of the week,
there's a nice summary round up.
And we're going to point
you to where that is.
So before we get
into that, let's
talk about cool
things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Let's talk about cool
things of the week.
I wanted to definitely
bring up a project that
was announced recently on
the Google Open Source Blog,
a project called OpenCensus,
which is a stats collection
and distributed
tracing framework.
We've probably talked
about this a little bit
in some previous episodes,
or at least those types
of things in previous episodes.
But this is actually
really cool.
It's an open source
project that is
meant to be a trace and
metrics open source tool that
will work with a
variety of back ends,
and stats providers, and
tracing things, like Zipkin,
or Prometheus, or Stackdriver,
and a bunch of other ones as
well.
It's really cool.
It's coming out of Google.
We should have them on the
podcast soon, which is--
MELANIE WARRICK: Which we will.
MARK MANDEL: But we will link to
the announcement blog post that
has some really pretty pictures
about what can be done with it.
As well as a medium
publication that is coming out
of the community from--
I hope I get this right--
[? Das Wilkin ?] talking
about using OpenCensus with
Prometheus and Stackdriver
as well.
So You can see some code
and some of the stuff
that people are
writing to use it with.
So I'm actually really
excited about OpenCensus,
so I can't wait to have
them on the episodes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And it's also nice that
it's analysis tool-agnostic.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, I really like that
about the platform, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: So another
cool thing of the week
is that the Zoological
Society of London
has teamed up with Google.
And they're using the
Cloud AutoML Vision tool
API that we
released, and they're
doing basically
facial recognition
on endangered species.
They're using a large set of
images that have been collected
from cameras in the wild.
They've had to do a lot of
manual labeling in the past.
But with AutoML
Vision, they're working
on trying to make that
more, of course, automated
and apply models, in essence,
to do facial recognition.
And the intent is
ultimately to help
with tracking
endangered species,
helping to reduce poaching.
I think their goals
for the future
are definitely to help identify
when there's injured animals,
so that they can help them.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's kind
of a cool application of it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, that's really cool.
Just thinking back from when
we were talking last week
about basically
being able to train
your models without having
to have a PhD or something
in machine learning.
That's a really
interesting application.
Also, I'm just
thinking about the fact
that now Google
Photos recognizes
my dog as a person in my life.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And it is a person in your life.
MARK MANDEL: It's very
much a person in my life.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Very understandable.
Well, and then the
last thing we wanted
to mention for the week is that
one of our colleagues, Felipe
Hoffman, has done a cool thing
where he went to Melbourne,
and he interviewed Graham Polley
from Shine Tech, who's a GDG.
And they basically did this
cloud data flow and tram
challenge where they were trying
to show that you can process
about half a terabyte of data.
And they had-- was
it 10.6 billion rows
of data while they were
traveling on the tram
down to Melbourne.
So basically, in 10 minutes is
what I understood from that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Graham has a track record
of doing these challenges
on various different
types of public transport.
If he can do things
within the timeframe,
like a train or a tram
goes from one place.
He's going to run out
of public transport.
MELANIE WARRICK: Has he
come to San Francisco
and done it on a trolley?
MARK MANDEL: That
needs to happen.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
probably needs to happen.
MARK MANDEL: That
MELANIE WARRICK:
But they do a video.
And the video is
really kind of cool,
so we'll post that up on
our show notes as always.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Well worth watching.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with Mike from Percy
and talk all about visual
continuous integration?
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
On this week's
podcast, we are joined
by Mike Fotinakis,
who is a Co-Founder
and CEO of Percy, Percy.io.
And so Percy is
actually this company
that's focused on visual diffs.
So Mike, welcome to the podcast.
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
Thank you so much.
I'm really thrilled to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And Mike, we'd like
you to tell us a little
bit more about yourself.
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So yeah, I'm the CEO
and Co-Founder of Percy.
And I don't know, what about me?
So I'm actually
an ex-Googler too,
so I've been using
Google products
for-- before they were actually
even called Google Cloud
Platform.
And yeah.
I love all things software
engineering and building
a team.
And the sort of
cross-sectionality
of things we like
to say we work on
is like, design,
development, and deployment.
So it's kind of
like where I work
is at the intersection
of those things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And Percy's this
startup that you've
been working on for the last
couple of years we were saying.
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, it started as a sort
of side project of mine,
of scratching my own itch at
a company I used to work for,
where we-- we were just
launching visual bugs all
the time.
And this is sort of a thing that
has plagued my web development
and software engineering career
forever, since I was actually
like 10 years old.
I finally got fed up with it.
And I was like, why isn't
there somewhere that just--
you can click a button
and do visual testing.
Like, why doesn't
that thing exist?
So I went off and
tried to build it.
And here we are.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And so that's where
that idea came from.
And I think I read that
it's Perceptual CI was what
it was originally named as.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Oh wow.
You really went into the
depths of the history there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Took a minute.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yes,
it was originally
called Perceptual CI,
which probably makes sense
if you're an engineer and
is terrible if you're not.
So my best friend
actually-- we already
had the mascot at the time,
which you see on our Home page
is Percy the
Perceptual Porcupine.
And the color scheme is purple.
So a little bit of alliteration.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where did
the porcupine come from?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: I don't know.
It just alliterated
with the rest of the--
MARK MANDEL: Alliterated?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It is kind of cute.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: And
then, my best friend
said, why don't you just
call the thing Percy?
And I was like, oh.
Well, Percy.io was
available at the time.
So we grabbed it, and the
rest is sort of history.
I spent a day
refactoring the code
to get rid of all the Perceptual
references, and here we are.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So just so I get this
straight in my head.
This is a continuous
integration system
that enables me to see UI bugs.
How does it see UI bugs?
How does that work?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yes.
So Percy's entire goal
is to really give you
confidence in every visual
change you're making.
And even in changes you're
making that you might not think
are visual.
So there's a bunch
of times when you're
making a back-end change.
And for some reason, it
manifests as a front-end bug.
And you might not catch
that if you're not
doing QA on the front end.
If you're not looking
specifically at that page.
If you're relying on
your own memory to like,
remember what the page
looked like before, this
is why things leak through
to production all the time.
We just miss the stuff.
So yeah.
So the way that Percy
approaches this problem
is to take a visual comparison
of what the state was before,
and then what the state
is after the code change.
And we do this in a
truly continuous way.
So I like to say--
we've sort of gone through a
couple of different iterations
of these phrases,
but I like to say
continuous visual
validation, or like
continuous visual integration.
So it's really meant
to bring the process
of doing this as early in
the software development
cycle as possible.
So the goal and the
way that Percy works
is I should be able
to make a code change,
and then immediately
look at Percy and see,
oh, I affected 900 pages.
And I didn't mean to.
I only meant to
affect one, right?
And so what we'll show you
is like, a visual comparison.
What we call a visual diff.
And these visual diffs are
basically just a comparison
of two different images
without any context
necessarily about what
the images are about.
They're just like, these pixels
have changed from these pixels
here on the left and
master to these pixels
here on the right in
your pull request.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know when
I've worked with GitHub before.
I mean, I go in and look at
the diffs between the code
and what's changed.
And I can see they
do like color-coding.
And you can look from--
one side is what
it was originally
versus the other side
is what I've changed.
So it's that idea.
But instead, you're seeing the
actual visual representations
of every single page.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: That's right.
So that's exactly
what we want to do
and the workflow process that
we want to allow, like designers
and engineers to work through.
Because you know, you
go to GitHub right now,
and you look on the left
and you look on the right.
And you're like, OK, this code
is changing from this to this.
And code review gives you
a lot of nice benefits
of like catching bugs from your
teammates who can understand
the code and the architecture.
Or they can say like, oh, this--
you don't need to
build it this way.
We have this other system
that does that now.
You don't need that.
So you get a lot of these
benefits out of the code review
process that aren't
necessarily like something
you would ever get from
a static analysis tool,
like a linter or something else.
And I think the
same exact workflow
and processes apply
to visual testing.
You want to be able
to say as a human,
like yes, these are the
visual changes we wanted.
We wanted those visual changes.
And whoops, we didn't mean for
this one to change that page.
That modal on that page
and that deep setting
state on your
billing page changed.
And like, you didn't even
mean to do that because you
weren't affecting that page.
And you didn't look at it when
you were making that change.
So yeah, we want to
give you confidence
that you know exactly
what you're changing.
In the same way that
a code diff gives you
confidence to know what you're
changing in your application,
like your test suites give
you confidence to know.
MARK MANDEL: So if
you're a developer
and you want to use
Percy, how does that look?
Is this a tool
that I run locally?
Is it something I can
integrate with a CI system,
like Travis or Jenkins?
What can I do with it?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah, exactly.
So we integrate with
CI systems right now.
So what you do is you plug
Percy into your test suites
that you're already writing.
You have these tests that
are like, visit this page,
click these buttons,
do this thing.
Or like, these components.
We want to test these
components in these states.
You integrate with your
CI, and then you push up
a pull request to GitHub.
And then as your CI runs,
it's pushing stuff to Percy.
And we've actually built a
full, like rendering environment
on top of Google Cloud
Platform that is this rendering
farm that's performing these
renders in the background,
doing these screenshots, and
handling all the weird edge
cases that go into that,
which we can talk about.
And then, we just notate
the GitHub PR and say, hey,
there's 15 visual diffs
here that need review.
And that might be right
next to your green check
mark in GitHub that says,
2,000 unit test pass.
Functionally, everything
is ready to go.
You're great here.
But then, Percy catches
it and says, hey,
you're about to launch
some visual changes.
Do you want these visual
changes, yes or no?
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And then, they can
basically go through
and do that review
side to side, and then
see and accept accordingly?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Exactly.
So that's a real goal, is
like give you a visual review
process.
MELANIE WARRICK: Like
you are in the GitHub
with the diffs between coding.
Are you also able to go
in and directly inside
the visual make
comments or say, here's
a spot that you might miss?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah, that's
definitely on our roadmap.
It's not something
we do right now.
You can sort of comment
in GitHub and say,
I noticed this thing in
Percy was wrong at the time.
Or, you changed this page
and you didn't mean to.
But yeah, commenting
and that kind of like--
that's sort of to the
intersectionality thing again.
If we can help designers
and developers and PMs
facilitate all of
these workflows.
And you can say like,
hey, we need our PM
to sign-off on this change.
That's totally
something you should
be doing on the visual
side of your site.
And like, on the changes that
you're making at that level.
So we sort of have a
pretty basic workflow
for that right now.
We try to keep it really
simple, so you can just iterate
and improve things very easily.
But more complex
workflows are definitely
on the roadmap of
things we want to do.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
So let's get under the hood.
I want to hear about how
this thing actually works.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: OK.
Well, I give a 45-minute
tech talk on it,
so what pieces would you like?
MARK MANDEL: All right.
I'm guessing the
most interesting part
is the image
analysis part of it.
I'm willing to
guess, I don't know.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: How does that work?
I'm guessing that's a fairly
computationally-intensive
workload?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Well, OK.
So yeah, a lot of it is pretty
computationally-intensive,
but it's probably not
the part that you expect
is computationally-intensive.
So basically, in the
talk that I give,
I basically show you like,
what is a visual diff
in the first place?
What is a visual diff?
And I just show you two images.
And then, a visual diff is just
the difference between these.
Computationally, what
is the difference?
What's the delta between
these two images?
So it's basically a transparent
PNG with red pixels on it.
And the red pixels tell
you which pixels have
changed between the two states.
So like these pixels have
changed between these two
states.
So generating those
visual diffs is actually
one of the cheapest
parts of the process.
You can literally run, like an
ImageMagick compare command,
and give it two images,
and give it a diff output.
And then, you open up the diff
and that's the difference.
And you can apply a bunch of
like, translucency and effects
and stuff, like--
as deep you can go
into ImageMagick there.
Or [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Bevels,
and like, gradients.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah.
You can rewrite this in Go as
your own like PNG interpreter
thing.
Do whatever you want.
The hard part about this
system- and the part
that we rely a lot on own
infrastructure, and on GCP
to do and to scale for,
is the actual rendering
of the screenshots.
So there's a bunch of
problems that come along
with rendering screenshots.
Partially because browsers
are just super-complicated
nowadays.
The source code for
Chrome, I think,
is as large or almost as
large as the Linux kernel now.
It's massive.
And so these things--
we want to keep
browsers developing.
We want to keep
them really modern,
but they come along with all
of these rendering differences.
For example, the simple
one you can think of
is like animations.
It's like, what happens if
an animation is on a page?
Well, if you take a
visual diff of it,
you might get just a random
frame of the animation as
compared to the previous
random frame of the animation.
So what we do in
Percy, for example,
is we freeze the
CSS of the page,
or the CSS animations
of the page.
We inject some CSS that tries
to aggressively turn off
all of those animations,
so that we can freeze them
in a particular state.
Or like, we freeze animated
GIFs so that they don't progress
through their animations.
So we're just looking
at the first frame,
so we can make these renders
really deterministic.
That's the easy one
in a lot of ways.
The harder ones
are like, did you
know that GPUs don't
actually guarantee
that if you divide
two numbers, they will
be the same answer in the end?
Things like that.
If you compile software with
different optimization flags,
you might get--
GPUs might execute the
instructions differently.
So like, if you're rendering
a gradient on one machine.
If it's like a
GPU-rendered gradient,
and you render that exact same
gradient on another machine,
they might not be pixel
perfectly accurate.
Or like, a little
bit of an easier one.
So fonts.
If you upgrade the fonts of the
system that you're working on,
you might get weird, like
anti-aliasing artifacts
around the edges of the fonts.
If Chrome decides to make the
rendering better, which they
do all the time,
then you might get
weird anti-aliasing
artifacts, or weird edges
of different tiles.
Or just improved
rendering overall.
Or a new CSS feature.
So one of the big parts
of what we do at Percy
is we try to handle
this process for you
and give you a really
deterministic rendering
environment that handles
all of the complexities
of visual testing.
So for example, we freeze
the fonts of the system
and handle this in
a containerized way.
We freeze the
animations on the pages.
We handle the browser
upgrade process for you
and try to keep everything
modern under the stack.
So the sort of naive
solution to this
is, I'm running my CI system.
And I just tell it like,
hey, render me a screenshot
and put it to disk, or put
it in some artifact directory
and keep the screenshots
across the CI runs.
That's kind of how the
first iteration of Percy
actually started, right?
We were running
a Jenkins install
and it is just, like dumping
screenshots and running diffs.
And then, you kind of can sort
of well what's happening there.
If you do that, then
what happens is you'll
end up generating a bunch of
screenshots that end up being
slightly different over time.
And for reasons that you
can't actually control.
So that's one.
So like determinism, is
like the big problem.
And then, the other second
big problem is performance.
It can take 15, 20, 30
seconds to tell a browser
to actually render a full
page PNG of the image.
So if you end up doing a
hundred of those in a CI run,
which is not that
many UI states,
you might add 30 minutes
to your test suite,
which nobody wants to do.
And it's kind of like
a horrible thing, which
I think this performance is
like the big, big reason why
visual testing is not something
that every engineering team is
doing right now.
So the way that
Percy handles that
is by just making it completely
out of band of your CI suite.
We add basically no
overhead to your CI suite
at all, because all we do is
we send up these DOM snapshots.
We capture the state of the
page that you've rendered
in your testing environment.
So like, you have a test
that visits some page, clicks
a drop-down, and
then some JavaScript
is executed in Chrome
Headless, or something.
So then, we take the
DOM state of that page
along with the development
assets around it,
send them up to Percy,
and then render them
in our custom rendering farm.
So that allows us to, number
1, parallelize the entire thing
aggressively so we can
finish very quickly.
And really, truly live up to
our goal of being continuous.
And then, 2, it
allows us to control
for all of these variables
where you can't really
deal with those rendering
differences in your CI
environment.
And you wouldn't really want to.
So that sort of model
and that architecture
has given us a
lot of flexibility
to really make
Percy try to live up
to this continuous
part of our goal.
And really, bring this process
really early on in the software
development lifecycle.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I have so many questions.
MELANIE WARRICK: You go.
I've got questions,
but I want you to go.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Let's start with, what's the
Google Cloud Platform products
that you're using here?
You mentioned containers.
You sort of buried
the lead there
a little bit about-- it sounds
like that's maybe how you're
running the actual browsers?
I'm not sure.
But what does that flow look
like through the products
as you go?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: So
yeah, we've been
using Google Cloud Platform from
the beginning for everything.
And actually, Percy
grew up in a world
where containers were already
existing in some ways.
I sort of dealt with like early,
early docker bugs and that sort
of like early pain there.
But glad that we sort of bet
on that early on, because that
has just allowed us to
scale this infrastructure so
much more easily had
we done something else.
So yeah, everything
is containerized.
And that's how our full
deployment pipeline works,
and how we update our
rendering environments is
pushing these new containers
and pushing new versions.
We just recently,
actually, migrated off of--
I don't know if
you even remember,
like container-VMs from--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yes.
So before Google
Kubernetes engine even.
It was like a
version of Kubernetes
that kind of ran
on a single node
and didn't tell you
it was Kubernetes,
but it just had like a YAML
file you could give and run
a set of containers
on a single node.
So we moved off of that to a
full Google Kubernetes engine.
Also, thank you for renaming
it from that to that.
It makes a lot more sense now.
Yeah.
So GKE is now a big
part of our workflow.
It's enabled us to get
to continuous deployment
really quickly.
And we are actually doing that
now where as of just a month
or two ago, all of our things
are continuously deployed.
And we've sort of
moved into that world
very quickly as we've been
able to adopt more Kubernetes
features.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I'm just trying to
work through the flow.
So you said they
have a DOM upload?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Where does that go?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: So yeah
MARK MANDEL: I'm
just trying to--
MIKE FOTINAKIS: I'll walk
you through the cycle.
So a DOM snapshot gets
uploaded to Percy.
We figure out like,
OK, what browsers
do you want to render this in?
Because it's a DOM snapshot,
we can also resize the browser
to different--
MARK MANDEL: Where does the DOM
snapshot actually go, though?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Oh,
Google Cloud Storage.
MARK MANDEL: It goes to storage?
OK, cool.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Sorry.
Yeah, it goes to storage.
So we start in
Google Cloud Storage.
And then, if you think about
it, we actually have to reload.
We have to reconstruct
the state of the page
that you had in your test
environment perfectly
in our environment.
So what we have to do is
startup Chrome, for example,
or Firefox, and run a proxy
there to actually say,
oh, you were loading local
host something index HTML?
Great.
We have that over here
in Google Cloud Storage.
We proxy all of these
assets using a proxy
that we've written in Go.
And then, we load
up Chrome running
in one of these containers
and we render the page.
We proxy all of your
development assets as well.
So like, we have to do
this because we're not
rendering live sites here.
We're rendering stuff that's
in CI, in development.
It's really early
in the process.
So we need to be able
to access and run
things that are your
development assets that
came from your test suite.
So we can't just
rely on the fact
that your assets might exist
in production somewhere.
And you might have a CSS
file sitting live accessible.
So we proxy all of the assets,
including the raw DOM snapshot
that you gave us.
And then, potentially
resize the browser
and do a bunch of
different sizes
that you might have
specified to say,
we care about this page
on mobile, on desktop,
on tablet sizes.
Render those screenshots.
Do the ImageMagick comparison.
Do the actual diffs.
Upload those, Google
Cloud Storage.
And then, yeah, this
is all sort of--
the back end is all
like a Rails API
too, that's sort
of orchestrating
some of this process.
And then we also
have a Redis queue
that's helping facilitate
some of the pieces, too.
MARK MANDEL: Are you running
Kubernetes jobs for this,
or your own sort of
batch queue process?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Our own
batch queue process, yep.
Yeah.
It's actually great to see
the sort of platform effects
of different providers, too.
So we like use Redis Labs
for our Redis provider.
And they just have a GCP option.
So sort of say, GCP, put it into
the same zone we're close to.
Great.
We have a Redis host that we
don't have to manage Redis for.
So
We do that with quite
a bit of our stuff.
And we use Google Cloud SQL,
which has been really great.
Yeah.
It's all like MySQL
5.7, or whatever
the latest one is there.
And yeah, it's
been really great.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you said
you're also using [INAUDIBLE]??
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yes.
So we recently--
over the last year,
we've sort of migrated from
heavily using the Google Cloud
HTTPS load balancer to running
our own layer 7 load balancing
stack.
MARK MANDEL: So why?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Good question.
It was sort of driven
from a lot of things.
We wanted to do more, like
traffic splitting experiments.
We want to be able to like
canary releases a little bit
easier.
The Google Cloud load balancer
is really great and very
performant overall, but there
were some features in there
that we started
having some issues
with that we wanted to be able
to have full control over.
So for example, like we want
to be able to internally retry
post requests if they fail,
which the Google Cloud load
balancer only
retries get requests.
And actually, that was
undocumented at the time, too.
I sort of just only knew that
because I was an ex-Googler
and I was like, oh,
I know that this load
balancer, like
retries get requests,
but will never retry post
requests because they're not
[INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, we wanted to sort of
have more control over that.
And then, as Percy's
infrastructure
gets more and more complex,
we have more and more
microservices that
sort of fall out.
And like, draw a boundary
around that service
and say, ah, that makes
sense as a microservice.
So we wanted to be
able to sort of control
the internal RPCs
and how things are
flowing throughout
the system, and how
we can orchestrate that stuff.
And as our development
team grows,
give them more ability to just
change one part of the service
rather than changing
a huge monolith.
MELANIE WARRICK: So since you're
from Google or an ex-Googler,
is that why you went
with GCP to begin with?
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
That was part of it.
I think a lot of it
is because it started
as a side project of mine, too.
So I was heavily optimizing
for costs in some ways.
And so my favorite
Google Cloud product
is actually the Google
Cloud Pricing Calculator.
I know that sounds
crazy, but it just
gives me so much
visibility as somebody
who is like paying for it
out of my own bank account
at the time to say, like,
oh, I will know exactly I'm
going to spend that this
month on this thing.
And so as we were
bootstrapping it early on,
that gave me a lot of
confidence to know.
And also, because I knew
that this needed to scale.
I knew that it just
needed to be able to--
if you're going
to have something
that can be truly continuous
for everyone's workflow,
it has to be
horizontally scalable.
You have to just be able
to say, oh, you need
2 million snapshots a month?
Great.
Here's a bunch of workers
and renderers for you.
You just need that ability based
on the DOM snapshotting model
that we have.
So I sort of bet on
Google Cloud platform
there because, yeah, it
just made a lot of sense
for the infrastructure
that we needed
and the scalability
that we needed.
And also, as an
ex-Googler, I knew
how good Google's networking
technologies are, for example.
And just how
world-class that is,
like more than most people know.
It's just really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did not
feed that to you before.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: They didn't.
I'm not a Google Cloud
rep at this point.
MARK MANDEL: Your ice
cream's coming later.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Thank you.
My affiliate fees.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, actually let
me ask then, what
have been some of
the challenges you've
hit up against by using GCP?
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
Well, let me flip
that question a little bit.
So like, Kubernetes fills
in a lot of the gaps, right?
If you want to run
your own infrastructure
and orchestrate it--
if you can sort of
get through the learning curve.
If you can understand the YAML.
Understand all the
pieces, like what
you're pointing at what
things, then all of a sudden
you can run your own
infrastructure as a service
and not have a full-time DevOps
person doing it and managing it
every day, or a team.
So it's given us a lot of
flexibility in that way
because we actually
could-- if we needed to,
we could move off
of Google Cloud
quickly, because
all of these pieces
are sort of cloud-agnostic.
And I know that plays into
sort of Google's like--
we want to really make
the stuff high-quality
and make it so you don't feel
like Cloud lock-in and all
of this stuff.
So yeah, some of the challenges.
I guess-- yeah,
getting visibility
into some of the deeper
inner features of what's
happening inside of the load
balancer and that kind of stuff
can be kind of
challenging sometimes.
That's the biggest
one I can think of.
MELANIE WARRICK: So in terms
of where the product's going,
what can you share with
us in terms of your plans
for future outside of--
you had mentioned
before about wanting
to be able to directly edit
inside of the visual diffs.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah.
So if you think about it,
Percy is all about workflow.
It's nice to be able
to say like, oh, we
caught a visual bug.
Oh, we had this
visual bug that kept
happening on our Home page.
And we got Percy
and we fixed it.
We're never going to launch
that visual bug again.
Great.
Visual regressions
are a big part
of what drives people
to adopt visual testing.
But the long-term
goal is all about
facilitating more and
more of those workflows.
What other pieces can
we pull out and sort of
automate away from the things
that the software delivery
lifecycle is doing right now?
So if you think about it,
there's a big gap between,
I've created a pull request.
Somebody is reviewing it.
And I'm merging
it to production.
And that gap can be
a bunch of things.
It can be your
deployment processes,
like continuous deployment,
if you can get there,
really helps close
that gap quite a bit.
But one of the big last pieces
that we just haven't automated
at all--
for some reason, like this
it just didn't exist--
was the ability
to say, like, yes,
I have full confidence to
know what visual changes are
going out as part of this
release or as part of this
commit.
And so that's really
what we want to do is,
every piece around
like confidence
around the deployments
and around those steps
is what we're aiming to do.
So you can imagine
you could have
comments on the visual diffs.
You could say, oh, this
particular part is broken.
You could collaborate.
You could say, hey, the
designer on our team,
she needs to go check this
out and see why that's broken.
Or like, yeah, we have a
bunch of stuff on the roadmap.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
I can imagine, too.
I know with machine learning and
the rise of machine learning,
that the actual UI is constantly
being built to be flexible,
to change, to be very just
not too hard-coded with.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I'd
assume that you're also
constantly thinking about,
if you're going to do--
continue to grow
that visual diffs,
like how that will
adapt as the UI changes.
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So machine learning
and computer vision
can be a big part of what
we can do to automate
the stuff in the future.
There's also a big,
hard problem there,
which is, how do you know if
a visual change is correct
or not?
And that's a human part, right?
Because you can say
as a human, yeah, I
meant to change that from this
to this or no I didn't, but
getting computers to
understand intent like that
is a pretty difficult problem.
So I can see us
going there over time
as we gather more data around
like, oh, people are approving
things that look like this.
Or they've hinted
to us that like,
this is an appropriate
visual change.
Or we know that
this change looks
like all of these other changes
and therefore it's also OK.
And Google Cloud has a bunch of
computer vision APIs and things
like that, that we might
be able to leverage
to get closer to
that kind of goal
where we're presenting to you
the most relevant changes.
Here are the most relevant
visual changes for you.
And try to knock down the
amount of potential noise
or the potential for
just an overload of data,
because you want
these visual reviews
to be as small as possible
and as targeted as possible
in a lot of ways.
MELANIE WARRICK: On
a different note--
I know when we were talking
before we started recording,
I was saying how I'd be
curious to hear, just
on a little bit of a side
note, what it was like.
I mean, you said
you woke up one day
and you had the idea for Percy.
But you didn't just snap your
fingers and you had a company,
I'd assume.
Unless you did, and
that's pretty impressive.
What was it like?
Can you tell us a
little bit about what
it was like going from,
I've got the idea,
to now I'm actually
running a company.
MIKE FOTINAKIS:
Yeah, absolutely.
It sort of started as
like, is this a project?
Is this a business?
How big is the opportunity here?
Those kinds of questions.
I had decided early on to
sort of bootstrap the company
and see how far I could take it.
And get some, just
validation around like,
OK, do people feel this pain?
Is this just a
pain I was feeling?
Is this a pain everyone feels?
And so when I started
realizing that like,
there's really no one that
doesn't have this problem.
It doesn't matter what
your tech stack is.
It doesn't matter, really,
what product you're building.
If you're on the web, or if
you're on mobile, or if you're
building something that users
are touching or looking at,
you have visual needs.
And so then, my co-founder,
Tim, and I joined forces.
And we were like, OK, let's
take this as a real opportunity
to build a company around this.
And that's just been such
a thrilling process for me,
because this is my first
company and thankfully Tim
has a lot more
experience in that way.
We're both engineers by trade,
but he is on multiple companies
now.
So it's good to have him as
sort of my rock in that way
to help me sort of
realize what's important
and what's not as we go
through our day to day.
And yeah, it's been
a great experience
to sort of see like,
even though we're still
a small team, that we can
really execute really quickly.
And that that actually matters
to our customers quite a bit.
So if you're a solo
person working on it,
you just only have
so much bandwidth
to address customer needs,
to do sales, to do marketing,
to do conference talks, to
do all the pieces of it.
And actually, really
build the machine
around getting the
info out there.
So yeah, getting more help and
building the team around it,
and really realizing that people
are inspired by this problem.
It's a hard thing to solve.
But when you realize that you
just saved an hour, and then
you just saved another hour.
And then you just
saved another hour.
Every time you're
making these changes,
it's such a drastic
shift in the way
that even our own team
develops our own software.
We have a designer who
just joined us recently.
And you know, he's using-- if
he does a redesign of a certain
part of the app or a
certain way that we're--
the header or
something on the app.
We have full
confidence that we know
exactly what is changing
in Percy every time
we change the app.
So he was making this really
big CSS refactor the other day.
He was adding all this really
modern CSS stuff, things
that I didn't even know existed.
And I was like, this is great.
And also, I don't have to even
look at this too carefully
in some ways because
we know with confidence
exactly what pixels are going
to change at the end of this.
So we use Percy as our own
sort of like dogfooding
to know exactly
what we're changing
in our own application.
And it's saved us a bunch of
times where on the billing
page, we were going
to lose a button that
was really important that
needed to be there all the time.
And it was just gone once
because of some change.
And you know, you catch
that before it even
reaches your customers.
So that kind of
stuff has been really
fun to see as we built
the company side of it,
like our customers have
those same problems,
have those same issues, no
matter what their tech stack,
what their sort of environment.
If they care about the
design or the stability
of their application
at all, then they
care about the visual
side of their sites.
So yeah, that's been a
really thrilling experience.
And I also have
learned that I love
wearing multiple
hats all the time
and sort of switching
between them.
It can be very--
I don't know, like a lot
of emotional overhead
can go into being the
founder, which is something
that I'm learning and
sort of anticipating.
So it's a lot of emotional
context switching.
You need to be able to be
in a meeting at once that's
sort of like a drag or
is like really hard,
and then you need to
move to the next meeting
and be really happy.
And you need to move
to the next meeting
and not say that one thing.
It's just emotional
context switching over
and over and over.
So it can be thrilling if you
have the right team behind you
and really inspired to
work on the product.
And really, make it better.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, we are running out
of time just a little bit.
But before we go, is there
anything we haven't mentioned,
or something you want to
plug, or an event you're
going to be at, or
anything cool that's
going on that you
want to make sure you
mention before we run away?
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Yeah.
You can always contact us.
We have a little Intercom
button on our site.
Feel free to reach
out and say, hey, we
were thinking about checking out
visual testing for this thing.
We're happy to chat.
We're also going to be up at
EmberConf in Portland in March.
I think it's March 11 and
12, somewhere around there.
MARK MANDEL: We'll check it
out and put it in show notes.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Great.
And yeah, we'll be up there.
We'll have a booth.
We'll be talking to people.
And we're sort of always around.
And we're in San
Francisco in the area,
in case anybody wants to
come by and chat about this.
It's a pretty early team, pretty
early problem in a lot of ways.
We have a lot of
traction in that way
and are excited
about the future.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, we're so
glad you joined us.
This is great to
hear about Percy
and how you're solving
problem-- solving the QA
process with visual diffs.
So thank you so much.
MIKE FOTINAKIS: Thank
you, guys, so much.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mike.
That was great to talk to you
about what Percy is doing.
And also, to learn a
little bit about how
we can look at visual diffs
and do QA around visual diffs.
I definitely think that's
a helpful tool to have.
Now, Mark, question of the week.
If I want something to read,
because I don't have enough
to read right now, but I
need something that's going
to summarize the news for me
for the week-- because there--
MARK MANDEL: There's
a lot, usually.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--a lot going on.
Where do I go?
MARK MANDEL: One
of our teammates--
I'm going to totally
massacre his last name.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, I love it.
We have so much fun with
names on this podcast.
MARK MANDEL: He's a Developer
Relations Program Manager.
He manages a bunch of
our internal programs
here at Google that work with
a bunch of different people
outside of Google as well.
Great fellow,
Aleksei-- oh my god.
Alexi Musin-Pushkin.
That's probably not bad.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
think that's good.
MARK MANDEL: I
think that will do.
Anyway, he does a weekly
medium publication
that I thought it would be worth
mentioning, strangely enough
called "This Week in Google
Cloud Platform," where
he basically does little
summaries of what's happened
in the past week, giving
you sort of titles
and little descriptions
on what's going on.
And he also does this
picture of the week showing
a little snapshot of
something interesting somebody
has done on Google
Cloud Platform.
So if you're looking for
something sort of weekly, that
sort of does a nice summary
and ends up in your feed,
or on your medium feed once a
week, you should check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or
if you need ideas
for cool things of the week,
you should check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
We will definitely have
links in the show notes.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Well, Mark, I think that wraps
it up for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: I know
you're off soon.
You're off to London.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm in London.
As we speak.
MARK MANDEL: As this comes
up, you'll be in London.
MELANIE WARRICK: We don't
pre-record this at all.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
in London as we speak.
And you are--
MARK MANDEL: I'll still
be in San Francisco.
Yeah, still just
going [INAUDIBLE] game
developers conference in March.
And nalby at FOSDEM.
AM I saying that right?
It's FOSDEM.
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
FOSDEM.
Let's go with FOSDEM.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
where I'm going to be.
MARK MANDEL: How else
would you pronounce it?
Foes-dim?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm going
to be there this week.
That's basically in Brussels.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]